I'm Dr. Oguchi Nwosu. I'm an Associate Professor in the Department of Family and Preventive Medicine.
Because I'm family medicine I deliveries.
It’s a special part of what I do.
I actually finished obstetrics and gynecology before family medicine.
I went to medical school in Nigeria and then I did obstetrics and gynecology in the United Kingdom
and then I did family medicine New York prior to serving in Georgia.
I was born in a city called Enugu in Nigeria, it's in the eastern part of Nigeria,
but I actually grew up mostly in the western part of Nigeria, which is a city called Lagos,
and I schooled in the northern part of Nigeria.
I am married, I have three boys. My wife is also from Nigeria.
I love to teach. I teach residents and students, for both the inpatient as well as the outpatient setting.
We do bedside teaching. In terms of getting residents to have what could be broadly described as
“great bedside manners,” which includes compassion, listening culture, and all those kind of things,
the best way to do that is you need to demonstrate it.
The center of the tripartite mission of your teaching of research, teaching, and you know,
being a clinician, if you start with the patient you can get all of those things accomplished.
I see myself as a clinician giving day to day patient care, but of course I'm at an academic institution
and I do have some areas of focus my research.
I have a particular interest in cervical cancer prevention as well as treatment but particularly prevention.
I'm currently working with some researchers at Emory and we're hoping to some particular primary focus on HPV vaccination and prevention.
The uptick of HPV vaccination, even as would it be readily available, is fairly poor,
okay, less than 50 percent in many states.
I think we can do better that given that this is something that can actually prevent cancer in the future.
The way I see legacy whether in medicine or in life in general is actually more an individual thing.
I want them to feel like “Hmm, this guy cares.” It matters to me that they see me as being, you know, caring
and trying to leave a positive imprint in them.
We get so focused on the disease and the medicines and all that and we forget
that behind that disease and behind those medicines or whatever treatments is a real person.